diese Bilder hier sind gerade mal ein
knappes Jahr her damals aufgenommen an
der Grenze zu Belarus tausende
Flüchtlinge Menschen die an die Grenzen
drängen die bereit sind wirklich alles
für ein Leben in Sicherheit zu geben da
ist das bald auch wieder unsere Realität
Städte und Gemeinden schlagen jedenfalls
Alarm sie warnen die absoluten Zahlen
die sind so hoch wie 2015 und 2016 mehr
als 1,1 Millionen Menschen haben dieses
Jahr schon Zuflucht in Deutschland
gesucht und es werden immer mehr und
deshalb steht nun auch Innenministerin
Nancy fazer ziemlich unter Druck sie
hatte heute einen Gipfel einberufen ja
Vertreter von Städten Gemeinden und
Landkreisen Tagen in Berlin heute genau
zu diesem Thema und das Ergebnis
präsentierte nennt sie Feser jetzt
wir haben eine ich will das nicht
verharmlosen wir haben eine angespannte
Situation deshalb haben wir uns heute
abgestimmt wie wir unsere Hilfe für
geflüchtete bestmöglich miteinander
koordinieren auch im Hinblick auf die
Wintermonate die vor uns liegen wir
haben seit Kriegsbeginn mehr als eine
Million Menschen in Deutschland
aufgenommen und versorgt zu einem sehr
großen Teil das wissen sie Frauen und
Kinder die vor Putins Panzern und
Raketen geflohen sind es ist ein großer
humanitärer Kraftakt die geflüchteten
aus der Ukraine gut zu versorgen
Unterkünfte bereitzustellen Kitas und
Schulen für die Kinder und ihnen soziale
Unterstützung zu geben
so darüber wollen wir sprechen mit Ralf
schulerleiter unserer
bildparlaments-redaktion ralf hat dich
dieser Gipfel überzeugt
solche Gipfel überzeugen in der Regel
grundsätzlich nicht weil es eigentlich
schon Veranstaltungen sind bei den
Fachkunde ins Schaufenster gestellt wird
oder aber gar nicht erst zum Zuge kommt
da treffen sich die höchsten Spitzen aus
der Politik und nicht diejenigen die
wirklich Ahnung haben wenn dort
beispielsweise ein Bürgermeister einer
beliebigen Großstadt in Deutschland
aufgetreten wäre der hätte das ganz
anders formuliert als diese
wohlgesetzten Sätze von Frau Feser wie
genau hätte er das formuliert er hätte
gesagt unsere Einrichtungen laufen über
wir haben große Probleme mit den
Sprachkursen wir haben riesige Probleme
mit den unterrichtsplätzen und wir
wissen nicht wie wir das alles bezahlen
sollen denn das Problem ist die Kommunen
sind dafür zuständig die müssen die
Gelder auszahlen bekommen ein Teil vom
Land wieder sehr kompliziert versteht in
Deutschland ohnehin nur kaum jemand und
der Bund beteiligt sich an den Kosten
bis das bei den Kommunen dann am Ende
wieder ankommt das dauert und so lange
gehen die in Vorkasse das ist ein
Riesenproblem wir haben es 2015/16
gesehen da hat die Bundesregierung im
Jahr zwischen 22 und 25 Milliarden Euro
aufwenden müssen um etwa
1,2 bis 1,8 Millionen Menschen
unterzubringen zu versorgen und so
weiter wenn es jetzt wieder dahin kommt
das tonhallen belegt werden dann haben
wir auch noch das Problem in den Schulen
dann sind die Eltern sauer die ohnehin
sich Sorgen machen wegen der
Energiepreise und der steigenden Preise
das ist ein sehr ungutes Gemisch und man
kann der Innenministerin nur sehr viel
Glück dabei wünschen diese Krise zu
entschärfen denn die 48 Milliarden
Sicherheitsfonds für Migrationen die
Schäuble als Finanzminister aufgehäuft
hat die haben wir jetzt gerade
verschoben und wollen sie verfrühstücken
in einem Fond für die Bewältigung der
Energiekrise weil da auch jeder Euro
fehlt das wird einfach sehr sehr knapp
hinzu kommt das ukrainische Flüchtlinge
deutlich besser gestellt sind als
herkömmlich Asylsuchende weil die und
dann ist Asylbewerber leistungsgesetz
fallen etwas weniger bekommen und die
ukrainischen Flüchtlinge bekommen gleich
den vollen Harz vier Satz inklusive
Erstausstattung für Wohnungen weiter und
den Wohnungsmarkt entlastet natürlich
dieser flüchtlingsantrag auch nicht wird
das Thema Flüchtlinge deiner Meinung
nach von der Politik vernachlässigt
absolut also wir haben im Augenblick
einen regelrechtes Schweigekartell
eigentlich aller großen Parteien die
Union wacht jetzt langsam auf die ist
ein bisschen gelähmt weil sie natürlich
die letzte große migrationskrise
ausgelöst hat und thematisiert das hin
und wieder die die anderen Parteien
außer der AFD versuchen es eben nicht zu
thematisieren weil es wenig
Lösungsmöglichkeiten gibt Ukraine
Flüchtlinge müssen wir aufnehmen wollen
wir aufnehmen es kommen aber alle
anderen auch noch die Balkanroute wird
mehr und mehr frequentiert und an den
Grenzen gibt es keine Kontrolle und
keine Zurückweisung sollen jetzt
allerdings verstärkt werden hat Nancy
fazer angekündigt wollen wir noch mal
reinhören was sie genau dazu gesagt hat
wir werden die Grenzkontrollen unserer
Grenze zu Österreich weiter verlängern
über den November hinaus für ein
weiteres halbes Jahr diese Kontrollen
sind notwendig um unerlaubte einreisen
zu verhindern an der Grenze zu
Tschechien kontrolliert die
Bundespolizei deutlich verstärkt im
Rahmen der Schleierfahndung ich bin in
engem Kontakt mit meinen Amtskollegen in
Tschechien und Österreich nach unseren
Gesprächen haben sowohl Tschechien als
auch Österreich
Grenzkontrollen zur Slowakei aufgenommen
um es klar zu sagen die visapraxis
Serbiens ist inakzeptabel auch diese
trägt zu den Bewegungen auf der
Balkanroute bei
ja sie nutzt das Wort verstärkt aber wie
viel was genau konkret wird sie da nicht
man muss dazu wissen dass diese
Schleierfahndung im Grunde das einzige
Mittel ist was wir an den ganzen haben
wir kontrollieren nicht konsequent an
den Grenzen die Grünen Grenzen schon gar
nicht und die Schleierfahndung meint
dass im Grenz hinter Raum also auf
unserer Seite der Grenze bereits in
einem Raum von meinem bis zu 20
Kilometer die Fuße Kontrollen
stattfinden wo Menschen kontrolliert
werden aufgegriffen werden
verdachtsunabhängig heißt es eigentlich
aber natürlich hat man einen Verdacht
wenn man ein Auto anhält was voll
besetzt ist mit Menschen die nicht
europäisch aussehen und sie dann
kontrolliert das ist eine
minimalinvasive Methode aber es ersetzt
natürlich keine Grenzkontrollen dass wir
jetzt wirklich Bundespolizisten vermehrt
sehen an den Grenzen die wirklich
kontrollieren das heißt verstärkt nicht
das heißt verstärkt nicht und es würde
sonst auch zurück Staus auf der Autobahn
führen und man müsste dann wirklich auch
die Grenzen wieder befestigen das will
man nicht und die interessante Frage die
Frau Fräser nicht beantwortet was
passiert mit den Menschen die man
aufgreift in der Regel bringt man sie
dann zu einer Erstaufnahmeeinrichtung
und sie stellen einen Asylantrag das
dürfen sie auch dann tun wenn Sie
bereits in Italien oder anderswo auch
schon eingestellt haben dass
widerspricht dem schengensystem es ist
egal und was frau Schäfer natürlich
überhaupt nicht erwähnt ist dass es ein
Desaster ist eine eine geradezu
Kapitulation ihrer eigenen
Migrationspolitik denn die Ampel wollte
eigentlich in sogenannte chancenasyl
einführen dass eigentlich jeder erstmal
kommen kann kann Asyl beantragen er kann
versuchen Arbeit aufzunehmen er kann
selbst bestimmen wenn er unterschreibt
dass er so heißt wie er heißt dann
lassen wir das mal so gelten eigentlich
war dass die ganz große Tor auf
Initiative der Ampel die jetzt
eigentlich mit harten Mitteln
eingesammelt werden muss weil wir sehen
dass wir überfordert werden jetzt hat
Merkel den flüchtlingspreis des
un-flüchtlingswerks erhalten und sagt
bei der Verleihung sie ist auch
weiterhin für eine Willkommenskultur wie
ist das zu bewerten gerade jetzt wo er
nun die diese Krise quasi droht ja
Merkel kann natürlich von ihrem Kurs
nicht runter also sie würde es nie
über die Lippen bringen sich selbst in
dem Maße zu revidieren Sie das bei der
osterruhe einmal gemacht bei einer
kleinen Geschichte aber sie wurde nie
ihre Grundlinien der Politik revidieren
sondern bleibt dabei grundsätzlich unter
humanitären Gesichtspunkten spricht da
nichts dagegen es war ein europäischer
Alleingang der für viel Verwerfung in
der Europäischen Union gesorgt hat
Schwamm drüber man hat sozusagen jetzt
den guten Menschen in der Kanzlerin
geehrt das ist in Ordnung das stimmen
auch die Kirchen mit zu politisch war es
damals aus meiner Sicht falsch und es
war auch ein Desaster in der in der
Folgewirkung und es führt dazu dass wir
jetzt noch geringere Kapazitäten haben
wo wir die Ukraine Flüchtlinge
berechtigt aufnehmen müssten ansonsten
ist Merkel immer eine Meisterin gewesen
der gezielten anscheinserweckung
sie steht dazu bedeutet ja nichts sie
ist nicht mehr im Amt sie hat das nicht
mehr die Folgen zu tragen also da kann
man generös sein und
Willkommenskultur ist auch ein so
schwammiger Begriff eigentlich ein
Begriff aus dem aus dem Tourismus und
nicht so sehr aus der Migrationspolitik
weil entweder man hat Grenzen oder man
hat keine eine Willkommenskultur dass
man niemanden ins Gesicht schlägt der
einem entgegentritt das sollte sich
eigentlich von selbst verstehen dürfte
selbstverständlich sein Dankeschön Ralf
Schuler für deine aktuelle Einschätzung
[Musik]